-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
You know, I just want
to mention our partner
Ford has a new truck out,
the 2024 F-150 PowerBoost Hybrid
with Pro Power Onboard.
This thing is great.
You can use it to
power things up.
It's basically like
a mobile power source.
Anyway, it reminded me
of something
that happened to me
the other day.
The Roots and I were out
together, and we just...
♪♪
[ Laughter,
indistinct conversations ]
This is it, guys,
"The Tonight Show"
Winter Wonderland.
Soon, the whole neighborhood's
gonna be here.
This is going to be
the best one yet.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, man, I can't wait
to bite the heads
off of gingy-bread men.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't wait to kiss myself
under the mistletoe.
-Oh!
-I can't wait to munch
on some tree corn.
-And decorate the tree
with oranges.
-Oh, that's beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't wait to do
my spoken-word poetry.
Snow.
[ Jazz music playing ]
Snow falling.
Falling down.
Down to the, to the ground.
Now I hear all the sights and,
and see all the sounds.
And last night, I blacked out
and hooked up with a clown.
-Thanks, Tariq.
-Oh, yeah.
-Hey, Damon, I dare you to stick
your tongue to your tuba.
-Yeah.
-No, it's freezing out.
My tongue would stick.
-I double dog dare you.
-Ooh!
-I triple dog dare you...dawg.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the best party ever!
Nothing could go wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-We interrupt this broadcast
with reports
of widespread power outages
in the neighborh...
-Power outages?
[ Buzzing ]
[ Hissing ]
[ Squeaks ]
-Oh, no! This is a disaster.
What are we going to do?
-I have an idea.
[ Squish ]
That didn't work.
-Think, think.
[ Bells jingling ]
♪♪
I have an idea.
Excuse me, sir.
I couldn't help but notice you
drive a Ford F-150 PowerBoost.
-Oh-ho-ho!
That's right, little boy.
And it's got
a full hybrid engine.
-Yeah, well,
I was wondering if maybe
we could use your truck to --
-Power up your party,
little boy?
-Yes. You don't have
to keep calling me --
-[ Laughs ]
Well, I was on my way
to deliver some packages,
but, sure, I can help you out.
-Great!
♪♪
[ Squish ]
-Time to bring this
winter wonderland back to life.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Children shouting ]
♪♪
[ All cheering ]
-Now I hear all the sights
and see all the sounds.
-What?
-Hey, thank you so much.
This year, you and Ford F-150
PowerBoost saved Christmas.
By the way,
I never got your na...
name.
Wait. Where did he go?
-Uh, guys, look up there.
[ Bells jingling,
all cheering ]
-[ Laughs ]
Merry Christmas!
-Thank you...Santa.
[ Creaking ]
[ All groan ]
-Happy holidays from
your friends at Ford
and "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Thank you to
the Ford Motor Company Fund,
who are donating
all of those toys
to The Children's Center
in Detroit,
which provides support
and care for nearly
3,500 children annually.
Happy holidays, everyone!
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."